وزير السياسات الزراعيه والغذاء الاوكراني
ميكولا من ارتفاع اسعار الحبوب عالميا اذا
ما استمرت محاولات وعرقله تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه وقال الوزير الاوكراني في
تصريح لقناه الجزيره ان استمرار بلاده في
تصدير حبوبها شهريا دون اي انقطاع سيضمن
بقاء الاسعار العالميه ضمن هامش غير مرتفع
من الاسعار
اذا صدرنا حبوبنا شهريا دون اي انقطاع
ستبقى الاسعار العالميه ضمن هامش غير
مرتفع ولكن اذا وقعت افعال كالتي تحصل
الان او تحول الوضع الى الاسوا او لم
يتحسن عندها سيؤدي ذلك الى ارتفاع اسعار
الحبوب عالميا كما حصل العام الماضي فغياب
اوكرانيا عن السوق العالميه العام الماضي
لمده اربعه او خمسه اشهر ادى الى ارتفاع
الاسعار بين 50 الى 80% عالميا
ايضا ما قال وزير السياسات الزراعيه
والغذاء الاوكراني ميكولاس ستواصل العمل
مع شركائها من الدول العربيه
لتامين الحبوب لها
نريد استمرار بيع حبوبنا للدول العربيه
ونؤمن ان شركائنا من الدول العربيه لهم
الحق باختيار اي حبوب سيشترونها والواضح
انه لا توجد كميات كافيه من الحبوب
الاوكرانيه التي تباع ما يؤدي الى عدم
ارتياح لدى الدول العربيه بسبب الاسعار
ويجب اصلاح هذا الوضع عاجلا ام اجلا